what are predators of penguins uh uh
well in the ocean you'd have the big
ones like other larger and a crocodile
would eat a penguin all day for
crocodiles or a penguin it would not
[__] hesitate yeah but I don't think
there's like oh okay sure where where
are the crocodiles and Penguins I would
say the biggest I'd say their biggest
predator global warming
it's a vascular and Global Warrior yeah
global warming too much carbon in the
[__] sky or something now here's the
next question I got other ones oh sure
bikes with Spears
uh a turtle one of those big giant
turtles with the big chomping things not
that it would do it on purpose but it
would just roll onto one now how do
penguins protect themselves from
predators sharks they use sharks no no
they also